washes it down excellent footwork by
hachimora oh
irving the down court feed to durant
beautiful brotherly connection durant
and irving look at this
i see you man gets it up the floor quick
finish
the tatum as well and kimball walker was
the fifth option but he's been asked to
do more this season
and in this series the nice touch by
durant all right here's durant getting
to his spot so you got to fight him more
than that
you can't just let durant just get the
ball where he wants it
brooklyn has talked so much of just
having that sense of urgency
from the start of games and not putting
themselves in a hole
kevin durant from the free-throw line
pure
well if you played at virginia in
college you're going to be a good
defender under tony bennett there's
kevin durant with his first two points
remember he did not play in the first
speed
irving had an ocean now irving to the
paint
flips it out here's durant yes
went by williams who was going for the
for the block and
it here's durant hold for a final shot
irving durant 4-3 yes
[Music]
are you going to be wearing yours on
thursday you know what i think i will
i'll be sitting at home watching wearing
the game durant buries the three
i don't know why you would mark he's 61
on catch and shoots like joe harris is
ridiculous
with any kind of time and space
and so is that guy into rhythm looks
like it's happening pretty quickly going
to put his hand up
like hey i'm 6 10 and i'm a sweet
shooter find me
able to clear the board away holiday so
good
in the block correct quick release on
the three
over giannis three-pointer down for k.d
[Music]
[Music]
oh irving the down court feed to durant
beautiful brotherly connection durant
and irving look at this
i see you man gets it up the floor quick
finish
porter has been the story so far the
nuggets give it up and kyrie
give it to durant i could've just lost
that right there
know what they're trying to do kyrie
just reached him michael just loses it
and it's off to the races
[Music]
[Applause]
loose ball picked up
by the box and they can just ignite
these nets
kyrie irving with a beautiful pass to us
what up it's your boy adam lefkow do you
like that content i know you like that
content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report